[Music]
the results of the national elections in
Iraq was shocking but they weren't
necessarily surprising less than 45
percent of eligible voters cast a ballot
most didn't vote at all because they
were frustrated with the current crop of
leaders who consistently failed to
improve their lives
this explains why looked at a sutter's
siren coalition appears to have won a
narrow plurality solder has cultivated
his status as an archer a key
nationalist and the champion of average
Iraqis even still solder didn't win by
much so his ability to determine the
governing coalition let alone dictate
and dominated is going to be very
limited Prime Minister Abadi could
easily retain power as a compromise
candidate or the Iranians might squeeze
the various Shia parties until they
agree to Tehran's preferred candidate as
they eventually did back in 2010 but for
my money the most important question is
not who becomes prime minister right now
it's what happens when the government
fails to deliver better governance
because it's all too likely that they
will fail especially since the United
States seems uninterested in providing
the help and guidance that will be
needed for them to succeed do you think
that the Iraqi elections matter at all
for American interests let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI